drone d'endroits pour une rencontre et
le musée en fait souvent de belles comme
cette équipe de télé néerlandaise venue
tourner le 230e épisode de sa série
consacré au train pas comme les autres
oui ferme dans la région on a déjà filmé
la ligne des hirondelles très bien et
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à la ligne
des horlogers
à proximité
le train c'est le fil rouge de l'épisode
et on encourage les gens à monter à
descendre du train pour visiter
ce que l'équipe ne sait pas en revanche
c'est que d'ici Noël date de la
diffusion pas mal de choses auront
changé au musée comme ce vieux hangar à
biplan veut une tout droit de Sochaux et
condamné à disparaître jusqu'à présent
c'était notre lieu qui nous servait de
réserve et l'ensemble des collections
qui sont pas exposées dans le parcours
permanent du musée les collections du
coup il y a plus rien là il est vide il
y a plus rien puisque le bâtiment est
rongé par les insectes donc il va être
remplacé il va être remplacé par un
bâtiment neuf des réserves
fonctionnelles des vrais véritables
réserves de musées de nouvelles réserves
mais aussi une galerie consacrée aux
machines agricoles une résidence
d'artistes un accueil scolaire nettement
amélioré 10 millions d'euros au total
pour un nouveau souffle ça va vraiment
nous permettre de développer le musée
dans les années à venir de prendre soin
des collections davantage soin des
collections également et puis voilà
améliorer aussi le confort des visiteurs
et développer vraiment l'activité du
musée et étendre justement cette saison
qu'on qui aujourd'hui ne peut durer que
7 mois et pourquoi pas battre des
records de fréquentation au delà des 45
000 visiteurs par an le chantier démarre
dans quelques jours
et jusqu'ici tout va bien